la première fois que vous apparaissez à
la télévision c'est un gréviste déjà
enseignante grévistes mobilisés contre
la réforme fillon en 2003 et pour votre
future retraite
[Musique]
je vais partir à la retraite au delà de
2020 donc il faudra que bêtise jusqu'à
68 ans puisque j'ai commencé à
travailler à 26 ans et je partirai avec
30% de mon salaire net vous militez
depuis l'adolescence 17 18 ans depuis 18
ans depuis 18 ans surtout et et pourquoi
avoir choisi lutte ouvrière c'est vrai
que moi dès l'âge de 16 ans 17 ans
j'étais quand même révolté parce que je
voyais j'étais révoltée par par les
injustices part par la faim dans le
monde aussi il y avait eu en 86 une et
famine en éthiopie enfin voila je ne me
voyais pas ne rien faire voilà tout
simplement jeu pour moi c'était ce
n'était pas possible d'accepter ça je
voyais bien je voyais bien que ici en
france les poubelles record g etc
comment les ccc ces enfants ces femmes
mourir de faim je ne comprenais pas et
donc ma première impulsion s'était
finalement de d'aller vers les
associations humanitaires et puis au
lycée à lyon je suis parti faire un
sport études à à lyon j'ai rencontré des
jeunes des jeunes qui avaient des idées
qui avait des idées communistes qui
m'ont fait découvrir
donc le manifeste du parti communiste
qui m'ont fait découvrir les idées
révolutionnaires et qui m'ont fait
découvrir aussi la force du mouvement
ouvrier ça c'est quelque chose que
vraiment j'ai découvert parce que
j'étais moi même issu d'un milieu plutôt
commerçants agricole et puis tu vois la
rural et
j'ai découvert donc cette force là qui
avait déjà tellement fait pour faire
avancer la société et donc je me suis
cela m'a convaincu cela m'a convaincu à
l'époque il y avait le parti communiste
mais qui venait de gouverner qui venait
de gouverner qui était pour moi un parti
de gouvernement qui avait finalement
quitté dans le système donc non moi je
cherchais un parti attaché a vraiment
changé la société de fond en comble ça
devait être un parti révolutionnaire et
cela était lutte ouvrière
[Musique]